[موسيقى]
لقد تعرضت هذه الديانه ابان السنوات
العديده للاضطهاد ومحاوله اظهارها كطائفه
صوفيه
ولكنهم استطاعوا الحفاظ على عدد قليل من
المراقد ودور العباده التي تعرضت خلال
السنوات السابقه للكثير من التدمير
ومحاوله محوها كليا
رافقنا رجب ولاول مره الى احد مراقدهم
المهمه في مدينه كركوك
اليوم اتينا الى هنا لزياره الخنقه نحن
نسميه الخنقه هو المسلمون يطلقون عليه
مرقد الامام احمد وهو عالم كاكائي ومعظم
الخطب والمعارف الكاكائيه معتمده على ما
قدمه العالم المبارك خان احمد وهذا المرقد
والمزار موجود منذ ما يقارب من 500 عام
حيث في نخان احمد في هذا المكان
وتاريخ ديانه الكاكائيه في كركوك مرتبط
بهذا المرقد حيث سكن الكاكائيون حوله
وبالقرب منها وسابقا كان كل سكان هذا الحي
من الكاكائين والان نحو 60 الى 70% من
سكانه كاكائيون والباقي من التركمان ولو
دققت في تاريخه ونسبها اولئك تركمان لو
وجدت ان معظمهم يعود اما لعشيره الزنكنه
واما الى الكاكائيل